here's an interesting story that has
some people on the left sort of upset or
or
certainly at least concerned on august
17th
about eight days ago the democratic
national committee
removed language from a draft platform
a draft document calling for an end to
subsidies
of fossil fuel companies
and the democratic national committee
and joe biden
and senator kamala harris historically
have opposed fossil fuel subsidies
they've said they would end them and it
was in a draft document
and yet eight days ago the call for the
end to these fossil fuel subsidies was
quietly removed
why did it happen it's not completely
clear but there was huge
backlash a lot of climate activists saw
it
as a stab in the back many people
alleged that
look this is joe biden he said he was
going to do one thing and then they
quietly remove it from the document and
now all of a sudden they're no longer
against abolishing fossil fuel
subsidies which cost somewhere between
20 and 650 billion dollars each year
depending on what you include and how
you measure it
and a bunch of people reacted by saying
this exposes the true biden biden
doesn't really want to do the things he
claims he wants to do
on climate or on whatever else and
uh it's it's sort of biden showing his
true colors
now after the backlash it's been added
back in
and again it has been restated that
joe biden and kamala harris and the dnc
support ending subsidies to fossil fuel
companies
and of course the reaction from many was
and it's not a crazy reaction
joe biden doesn't really support it but
he only got shamed back
into it right now so you could chalk
this up to confusion you could chalk it
up to a misunderstanding you could chalk
it up to bad faith
i have to tell you it seems unlikely to
me
that what happened here is that they
really were trying to just
remove this pledge to end fossil fuel
subsidies
and they got caught and they put it back
in the way the dnc operates is
if they want to back away from some kind
of promise they do it and they come up
with flowery or non-offensive language
to
to defend it so i actually think it's
more likely that this was some kind of a
confusion or a misunderstanding but i
think
it's instructive in that it sort of
reinforces something i've been talking
about for a while which is
if joe biden wins we are getting the
ball back
we are not yet putting any points up on
the board to use a sort of football
analogy
and we're going to have to push joe
biden if he's president and we're going
to have to push him
for the entire time that he is president
so i'm not
hugely worried about this for two
reasons number one
um i i actually do think it was probably
some kind of a mistake or
misunderstanding
because this is not how the dnc would
probably do this
also more than likely if they didn't
plan
to end fossil fuel subsidies or even try
to they would just leave it in but then
just not do it and blame republicans
so i i just i think that that's probably
not the explanation
but either way we are going to have to
as progressive activists hold joe biden
accountable if we want to get things
done and put points on the board if he
indeed becomes president of the united
states
so i don't think this was some kind of
deliberate betrayal by joe biden his
campaign
seems to have been clear the whole time
and by the way i have to tell you
something else on this particular issue
of ending fossil fuel subsidies
it's going to be difficult to do in four
years it's going to be difficult to do
maybe even in eight years
it should be done we should be shifting
subsidies away from fossil fuels and to
renewables but in practice it's going to
be difficult to do it doesn't mean we
shouldn't try but
part of being able to do it is going to
be getting
off of these fuels in the first place
and it is kind of a chicken egg scenario
as we continue to be dependent on fossil
fuels it will be difficult to remove the
subsidies
and if we remove the subsidies it will
be difficult to get off of them because
the prices of fossil fuels will be kept
artificially low
by the subsidies themselves but it's
going to have to be
a sort of step by step by step but the
hot takes
that are saying this is proof of biden
this or
this is proof of biden that
joe biden's climate proposal would be
the most progressive of any president if
biden wins
and either way we are going to have to
hold him
accountable and that will be the mission
of progressive media i hope that's what
i'm anticipating my job to be
for the next four or eight years if joe
biden succeeds at removing donald trump
in november